في هذه الأثناء ، أريد الحصول على بعض
التحليلات من محللينا العسكريين
اللواء المتقاعد جيمس سبايدر مارك
هي هنا معي أه أنت هناك
تشاهد كل ذلك ما هو
رد فعلك على ما نراه
ونسمعه  المدينة التي يبلغ عدد سكانها ما يقرب من ثلاثة
ملايين شخص ، نعم ، شكرًا لك يا ذئب ،
دعني أريك شيئًا ما في
المقدمة إذا كان بإمكاني فعل ذلك من أجلك ، فإن
القوات القادمة إلى الكهف
تأتي في هذا الاتجاه ، هذا السهم
هو تقريب إذا كنت تدرك
ذلك  ما لدينا هنا هو نهر القراص
الذي لم ينشر الروس قواته
في هذا الاتجاه لأنه
كان عليهم القيام بعبور النهر أو
نوعًا ما كان لديهم فصل بين
القوات ، لذا ما نراه الآن هو أنهم
قادمون إلى keeve  دعونا نذهب نوعًا ما إلى
كييف ونرى كيف يبدو ذلك الآن ،
فعندما تنظر إليه عن
كثب مرة أخرى ،
ما هو مهم أن ندركه هو أن
القوات الروسية كانت في الأصل هنا
في المطار.  إنها المدينة
التي يعملون الآن في طريقهم إلى
المدينة عندما تأتي إلى مدينة بهذا
الحجم من 3 ملايين ، وهذا مقسم بشكل لا يصدق ،
حيث
تبدأ التضاريس في امتصاص
الأفراد ، كل هذا يتعلق
بقتال المشاة ، وهذا هو القتال المنفصل عن
هذه الاحتياجات  أن يتم القيام به خارج
السيارة ، ما نراه
الليلة على الأرجح هو التحضير
لساحة المعركة التي
لن تكون دقيقة جدًا ، ستكون
دموية
جدًا وستكون واسعة جدًا وستتسبب في حدوث الكثير من الأنقاض
نتيجة لإدخال
صاروخ إطلاق الصواريخ وربما
بعض النيران الجوية ، ما يحدث الآن
أيضًا هو أن الروس لا يقودون
المجال الجوي وهو أمر جيد
استعدادًا لذلك ، لذا فإن الانتقال إلى
المدينة هو الشيء الرئيسي بالنسبة للأوكرانيين في
هذا  النقطة الأولى ، لقد حصلوا على
ميزة ميدان الوطن ، لقد حصلوا على
التضاريس لمصلحتهم العظيمة التي
يحتاجون إليها للبدء في اتخاذ بعض القرارات الواضحة جدًا
حول ما إذا كانوا يريدون البدء
في التراجع  هذه الجسور عبر نهر نيبر
مرة أخرى إذا افترض الروس
أنني مخطئ وأن الروس لديهم قوات
هنا
، فسيتم فصلهم الآن عن
القوات هناك مما يمنح
الأوكرانيين ميزة كبيرة ولكن مرة أخرى
هناك الكثير من القوة التي يجب أن
تأتي  في من الروس